y
[Música]
ah
el mes de junio fue el más devastador
para colombia en cuanto a números de
muertos por kobe 19 en ese mes las
autoridades reportaron 17 mil 716
fallecimientos de los más de 106 mil que
registra hasta ahora el país es decir el
16 5 por ciento además según la ms
colombia es uno de los 5 países del
mundo que registró más casos nuevos la
semana pasada con más de 33 mil
contagios el pasado domingo el tercer
pico se ha prolongado por la circulación
de nuevas variantes apenas 18 millones
de personas de los 50 millones de
habitantes han recibido al menos la
primera dosis de la vacuna contra el
coronavirus y además colombia ha vivido
una serie de manifestaciones contra el
gobierno que ha provocado repetidas
aglomeraciones a pesar de este panorama
el gobierno avanza en la reapertura de
la economía aunque la menor llegada de
turistas extranjeros puede suponer una
caída de hasta el 23 por ciento del pib
[Música]
hace más de un mes que paraguay es uno
de los países con mayor cantidad de
nuevas muertes por coronavirus por
millón de habitantes en todo el mundo el
país sigue registrando en estas semanas
nuevos picos de contagio y muertes
diarias por ccoo y 19 las dos
principales causas de este colapso
sanitario son por un lado un sistema de
salud pública históricamente precario
que hoy tiene una ocupación del 100 por
ciento de camas de terapia y por otro
lado una campaña de vacunación aún
incipiente que sólo ha alcanzado a cerca
del 10 por ciento de la población total
de 7 millones de habitantes es en este
contexto que el gobierno del presidente
mario abdo benítez ha anunciado la
llegada de una donación de 1 millón de
vacunas pzifer por parte del gobierno
eeuu sin embargo las críticas a la
gestión sanitaria de abdo benítez
durante la pandemia persistirán debido a
que la gran mayoría de las vacunas que
fueron aplicadas a unas 700.000 personas
en paraguay hasta ahora fueron producto
de donaciones de gobiernos extranjeros y
no las compras hechas por el estado
paraguayo
[Música]
en uruguay luego de que en junio se
registraran récords de fallecidos y
contagiados por kobe 19 tras tres
semanas las muertes se redujeron a la
mitad de esto debido a una vacunación
masiva de la población y también la
cantidad de casos de personas que
transcurrieron por la enfermedad
actualmente el 34% de la población
recibió ya dos dosis de la vacuna se
espera que en los próximos días se
alcance el 70 por ciento de la población
y con ello la ansiedad e inmunidad de
rebaño el gobierno autorizó a partir del
5 de julio la realización de
espectáculos públicos y fiestas con
medidas sanitarias también a quienes
reingresen al país le exigirán un test
psr pero no será obligatorio realizar
una cuarentena de siete días en estos
momentos miles de uruguayos salieron al
exterior tras las vacaciones de invierno
algunos epidemiólogos cuestionaron las
medidas del gobierno porque temen el
ingreso de la variante delta al país
[Música]